loin des projecteurs
il cherche à passer inaperçu mais plus
on s'en approche plus on découvre son
côté menace à l'altération du pays qui
vont les employés quand l'avion à 29 est
un produit que les américains exportent
et il est livré toutes équipées miceli
dé saper des banques conventionnelles
nos guides et sap et des raquettes ou
des mitraillettes okah dans l'appareil a
beau être assemblés discrètement en
floride
il n'est pas à l'abri de controverses
qui se répercute jusque ici
la réalité est que c'est un avion
américain slash canadien cette question
fondamentale
quelques mois après son arrivée à la
maison blanche dans notre up allait
mettre tout son poids pour faire
approuver la vente de 12 avions à 29 au
nigeria un contrat de 600 millions de
dollars américains pour aider l'armée
nigériane a lutté contre le groupe
terroriste
boko haram est pourtant l'administration
précédente n'avait pas hésité à bloquer
la transaction
malgré les fortes pressions de
l'industrie et du gouvernement nigérian
une série de bavures militaires excluant
le bombardement d'un camp de réfugiés
par les forces nigérianes avaient
justifié cette décision de barack obama
l'attaqué avait fait plus de 230 morts
et des dizaines de blessés or fait peu
connu
les avions que doit vivre et les
américains au nigeria sont intimement
liés au canada le moteur du à 29
ils fabriqués chez pratt & whitney au
québec et en alberta
on sait reconnaître avoir connu meilleur
batteur pour ce catégorie d'avions alors
les retrouve dans presque toutes des
avions de tacler genre on appelle ce
tacle et jason brody que les attaques
font moins mal la rue sq que une moteurs
fabriqués au canada va être utilisé dans
une avion nigérienne par les militaires
dans une attaque où la majorité des
victimes sont des civils a est une
risque que nous ne pouvons pas prendre
cet exemple prend toute son importance
au moment où le canada s'apprête à
adhérer au traité sur le commerce des
armes
le gouvernement trudeau s'est engagé à
le faire mais sa démarche expose une
brèche
ottawa souhaite exclure de l'application
du traité tout le commerce militaires
avec les états unis
c'est à dire plus de la moitié de ses
exportations d'armes
nous avons la possibilité de contrôler
ses exportations mais nous avons décidé
de ne pas la faire
pour exporter des armes et du matériel
militaire les entreprises canadiennes
doivent obtenir un permis d'ottawa la
règle s'applique pour tous les pays
tous sauf les états unis cette exception
date d'il ya plus de 60 ans depuis
l'entrée en vigueur d'un accord
officialisé à l'époque du président
eisenhower du premier ministre saint
laurent peggy mais semaine est une
ancienne ambassadrice canadienne pour le
désarmement auprès de l'onu c'est les
américains qui décident la destination
des armes fabriquées au canada
et comme aucune licence d'exportation
n'est requise pour les ventes au sud de
la frontière
ottawa ne collige il divulgue aucune
donnée il vend ou dans quel pays a dans
call girl dans quel conflit or le canada
mise sur la bonne foi des américains qui
exportent maintenant dont plus de 120
pays
pas tous exemplaires -et les droits de
la personne sont très importantes pour
nous voilà plus d'un an que le
gouvernement a déposé son projet de loi
pour permettre au canada de respecter
les objectifs du traité international
malgré les avertissements des experts et
de l'opposition néo-démocrate toujours
pas question d'inclure les exportations
vers les états unis ce qui montre bien
les trous importants dans notre système
c'est un signal que le canada n'est pas
sérieux ne prennent pas les obligations
très sérieusement
visiblement l'industrie ne veut pas que
cette brèche soit colmatée
l'association qui représente 800
entreprises du secteur de la défense
insiste changer les règles du jeu
n'irait à la réputation d'affaires du
canada mais on ne voulons pas brusquer
l'industrie et les américains le canada
a créé beaucoup de mécontents c'est un
jeu très cynique du gouvernement
les experts n'hésitent pas à dire que la
démarche canadienne va à l'encontre du
traité aucun des 94 pays l'ayant ratifié
n'a prévu pareil exemption pas
d'exemption pour un pays où l'autre par
exemple si c'est interdit c'est interdit
c'est interdit cette violation d'une
obligation fondamentale du traité
calmer les craintes s'annonce plutôt
difficile pour faire fructifier le
commerce américain des armes dans nos 30
à la ferme intention d'assouplir les
règles d'exportation
il a une grande marge de manoeuvre les
états unis refusent d'adhérer au traité
alors encore plus de pièces et
composants canadien pourrait traverser
la frontière
mais comment le savoir et surtout
comment connaître leur destination
finale